a top south african scientist says there
has been a sharp rise in new covet cases
as new variant omicron spreads across
the country but dr michelle groom says
more data is needed before any
conclusions can be drawn about how
infectious and dangerous this variant is
so far omicron has been detected in over
two dozen countries it was first
identified in botswana and south africa
which has now been cut off from air
travel by many nations
here in europe the variant has been
detected and at least 13 countries from
norway and germany in the north to italy
and portugal in the south researchers
say they will need two or three weeks to
work out whether omicron is more
transmissible than the now dominant
delta strain whether it's resistant to
vaccines or causes more severe symptoms
than previous coronavirus variants
and let's go right to our correspondent
adrian krishi is standing by in
johannesburg at a school that is serving
as a vaccination center hi adrian
the the variant was first detected there
in south africa what more do scientists
know about omicron at this point
well sumi as you said it is still a bit
early we do not have much comprehensive
data at that stage but of course
scientists have made some observations
already it looks like that this variant
is more infectious than the previous
ones and that also counts for those who
already vaccinated and those who were
previously infected with other variants
and that is of course a concern in south
africa because the country has seen high
infection rates before and scientists
here were actually hoping that this
would help in this fourth wave to keep
numbers low but it doesn't seem to be
the case with the current reverend the
only thing that people are currently
putting their hopes into is that we are
not seeing high hospitalization rates it
doesn't look like this variant is
causes more severe disease and so this
is something that scientists are saying
give some reason to hope that we will
not see such a bad fourth wave in south
africa adrian what are health officials
they are doing to prevent contagion
the health minister today said that he
is hoping that there are no more
stricter lockdown measures necessary
which is an interesting statement
because many people here have expected
that that we will see stronger lockdown
measures the country is currently on the
so-called alert level one which is the
lowest lockdown level there's still a
night curfew but apart from that life
has been going on as normal here and the
authorities are hoping that vaccinations
can make the difference because we've
seen early data that um the omicron
variants can also at least it helps
against severe disease with the omicron
variant if you're vaccinated before the
problem is the vaccination rates here
have been very low less than 25 of south
africans have been fully vaccinated that
number is very low especially
considering that vaccines are widely
available that's why we're currently
here in front of one of the vaccination
centers at the school they have had a
very slow uptake and today the
authorities decided to do door-to-door
campaign in the area here trying to
convince people to get the jab we've
talked to some people here there's a lot
of hesitancy here many people believe
they will actually get sick once they
get the jab so they're trying to
convince them otherwise they're trying
to educate them and trying to push them
to go to get vaccinated before the
fourth wave is even getting worse
we mentioned that many countries are
trying to seal themselves off from the
omicron variant including with flight
bans
what does that mean for south africa
it's a total disaster for the south
african economy and it's exactly what
we've seen a year ago when south african
scientists discovered the beta variant
back then we saw the same measures south
africans were not allowed to travel to
certain countries tourism arrivals broke
down here's exactly what we're seeing
now again it's a disaster for the
economy we already have unemployment
rates of about 35
this is likely to increase in the next
months in a country that is having
massive poverty and inequality issues so
it's a massive problem and
understandably the president here was
quite furious about the announcement by
other countries to shut down the borders
because it is a big problem especially
for the tourism sector the season is
just about to start here everybody was
looking forward to december finally a
tourism season with a lot of tourists
coming in again but this is just not
going to happen once again
dws adrian kriesch reporting there in
johannesburg good to talk to you
india has confirmed its first cases of
the omicron coronavirus variant in the
southern state of karnataka health
officials say the two men who tested
positive are showing mild symptoms
according to local reports one of the
patients had arrived from south africa
while the other had no travel history
the news came months after a devastating
wave of the coronavirus that killed more
than 200 000 people in india only about
half of the population has been
immunized so far
and we can speak to our correspondent
standing by in delhi dw's nimisha
jaiswal hi nimisha
how are authorities reacting to this
news
well sumi the government here in india
has jumped to action within a day it
imposed new restrictions as well as
testing protocols especially on
travelers coming in from at-risk
countries of testing them at the airport
quarantining any positive cases and then
re-testing even the negative cases seven
days later to ensure that the virus is
not detected later either they're also
genome sequencing any tests of the
people coming in from actress countries
and also india has pushed its decision
to reopen all commercial pipelines in
the middle of december the health
minister has said that india has learned
a lot from the poverty crisis and has a
lot of resources and testing available
and the prime minister himself has
reiterated that the focus will be on
containment and second dose coverage
are people fearing a return to a
lockdown and the loss of income that
comes with that
concerns have definitely been spiked by
the omicron virus but they are not
reflecting on the streets as of now
india just went through a massive
festive season markets continue to be
crowded and many people continue to
travel finally getting a break from the
lockdowns that india did see earlier in
the year so while there are concerns
people are not reacting immediately and
anyway scientists as well as doctors are
watching closely encouraging social
distancing and masking and vaccinations
but the people so far may not be up to
taking up those restrictions again
and misha tell us what the vaccine
uptake is like in india at the moment
why 80 percent of the adult eligible
population has received at least one
dose there are concerns about people
coming back for the second dose given
that india has seen a serious fall in
cases under 10 000 cases every day right
now and this is coming down from a high
in the second wave of over 400 000 cases
so there are concerns about that which
is also why the indian prime minister
reiterated that we must ensure that
everybody has gotten their second dose
as well the
vaccination drive spiked in september
coinciding with the prime minister's
birthday but it has significantly slowed
down
dws nimisha jaiswal reporting there from
delhi thank you
joining me now from johannesburg is
shabi ahmadi he's a professor of
vaccinology at the university of vitwa
vitwatersrand mr muddy thanks for your
time infections are increasing rapidly
in south africa at the moment
is it because of omicron
uh great thanks for having me so yes it
is because of omicron and the main
increases in the whole tank province
which is where the variant
was first identified uh the positivity
rate the number of people that are
testing positive when tested has
increased from two percent two weeks ago
to more than twenty percent uh in a
period of two weeks in a number of cases
in the slope of increase uh of this
particular trajectory is much steeper
than what we experienced in the past
so omicron is certainly dominating
making up more than 90 percent of all
infections that are occurring at least
in route 10 but at the same time what is
important is that it seems to be an
unhinging of the case rate in a
community and hospitalization rate in
that hospitalization rate is much more
subdued than what we would otherwise
have expected based on amount of
infections that are taking place when we
compare with what occurred during the
course of the first three weeks right
there's also evidence to suggest people
are being re-infected that is people
who've already recovered from
coronavirus catching this new strain is
that true
absolutely the number three infections
are quite a bit including in our
longitudinal cohort studies in addition
to which the number of breaks or
infections in fully vaccinated
individuals is also quite substantial
but again most of those infections are
mainly mild disease we've already seen
very few if any
uh breakthrough in breakthrough cases
and fully vaccinated individuals that
are ending up in hospital you did make
mention that there was an increase in
hospitalization of children we just need
to be careful that all children at the
admitted to our facilities are routinely
screened for the virus irrespective of
whether they've been admitted for covert
or not most of the children that are
guessing positive are actually not being
admitted for cobalt and this is a
coincidental finding in children that
are being admitted at the time of the
peak of the wave in south africa when we
tested people at random up to about 15
to 20 percent of people were guessing
positive for for the virus when the when
when the wave was speaking so it's not
that children are more likely to be
admitted for covert they're just testing
positive for the virus
right um you mentioned vaccines there as
well but there's been some conflicting
information on vaccines do you know yet
if the current vaccines are effective
against this variant
so the leftist is currently underway but
i would be highly surprised given the
number of mutations affecting the spike
protein and particularly that part of
the spike protein against which the
antibodies sort of are able to
neutralize activity of the virus
the number of mutations suggest that we
would expect almost all of the vaccines
we have significantly diminished
activity against the virus but on other
end vaccines will also induce ecl
responses which are particularly
important when it comes to protecting
against severe disease and death so i
expect lots of breakthrough infections
to occur in fully vaccinated people but
those people will still be protected
because of vaccination
against severe disease yes we are as we
observed with a beta vagina and an
estrogenic vaccine as an example
okay well shall we marty professor of
vaccinology at the university of the
witwatersrand university in johannesburg
thank you very much for your time